with breaking news from the u.s the
white house says it's releasing 50
million barrels of oil from its
strategic reserves it's part of a
coordinated effort with several nations
to curb soaring fuel prices the biden
administration has come under increasing
pressure to act petrol prices have more
than doubled compared to a year ago
china india south korea japan and the uk
are also releasing oil from their
reserves live to our white house
correspondent kimberly hackett for more
on this kimberley why has the president
made this announcement now
it has a lot to do with the american
holiday season and the fact that the
american thanksgiving is already
underway in terms of the festivities
this is an annual holiday in the u.s
that pre the pandemic would see people
drive to visit family members great
distances and really is the peak travel
season in the united states and as a
result
given the fact that those numbers of
travelers are now back up to where they
were before the pandemic a lot of
americans not very happy about the high
gas prices that they're paying in
california as much as five dollars a
gallon here in the washington d.c area
closer to four dollars and that is
particularly high and hard for a lot of
working-class americans whose wages have
not kept up with the inflation that
they're experiencing so the u.s
president concerned about that he's got
low approval rating numbers right now
and it's not just energy prices but the
price of food and other items that are
also hard for americans giving the rise
in inflation so this is as much a
political move is it is an issue
of supply and concerns about the prices
as a result of those shortages and the
question of course is whether it will
work
yeah and that's the big debate now what
the white house is banking on is the
fact that this is being done in
coordination with other countries and
that could mitigate
what some are concerned is
potentially going to be just a
short-term
reduction in prices but that ultimately
could lead to higher prices that is what
the naysayers are saying is going to
happen in all of this but the white
house is really counting on the fact
that this is something that is being
done in coordination with other nations
as you reported and we should point out
very quickly that the strategic
petroleum reserves are typically
released for things like natural
disaster or other
sorts of issues not usually to alleviate
prices as the president is doing right
now it's about a one-month supply and
this is a bit of a gamble for the
president but in consultation with his
team he believes it will work because he
believes this is a situation created not
because of policy but because of the
pandemic we're going to wait to hear
from the president he's going to be
speaking in the coming hours about this
where he's going to make his case to the
american people kimberly thank you for
that kimberly harkett live for us there
at the white house
well earlier i spoke to rudy baruti
who's the chief executive officer of
energy and environment holding he says
the coordinated move will bring some
level of stability to oil prices
basically president biden decision to
start releasing from the sbr
is a very good move and it is one of the
strongest moves to dampen inflation
threat
if
opec plus and the saudis will not or
were not willing to increase their
production president biden had
three choices uh one is to ask u.s shale
industry to start boosting their
production this is one to use some of
the strategic petroleum
reserves that are
around 714
715 million
so what they have released now is around
seven
and if this is accompanied by india
china korea that is going to give a
major
stability to the oil uh
prioritizes and will give the level of
all prices to an economical sustainable
way especially after what we have seen
in the covered time